non bon soir
merci d'avoir choisi tout le monde en
parle
alors de nouveau au coeur du cyclone
médiatique depuis l'apparition aux
éditions privé d'un livre intitulé un
agent secret sort de l'ombre par pierre
martinet voilà alors ce pierre martinet
c'est un ex agent de la dgse reconverti
dans le dans le privé il raconte dans
son livre que sur ordre du directeur de
la sécurité de canal alors il ne cite
pas dans le livre mille le site dans la
presse gilles cas et lin qui est donné à
sa démission le 3 mai dernier donc sur
ordre de ce gilles cas et lun martinez
raconte avoir enquêté sur vous pendant
six mois en 2002 voilà ça doit faire un
choix que ça tu envie de voir les photos
de ta femme de tes gosses dans un
dossier n'a pas non plus et ça m'est
arrivé voilà donc c'est un peu un moment
s'ils ont des sentiments que j'ai envie
de garder pour moi ça pour l'instant et
c'est des trucs qui sont crades au
possible quand on le voit il faut le
voir le truc c'est assez crade et
c'est des sentiments aujourd'hui je
laisse pas ça à moi c'est mes sentiments
je m'occupe pas de ça il ya un dossier
comme ça c'est un truc de justice mme
way alors l'époque un 2002 c'est
l'arrivée de xavier couture à canal plus
après le limogeage de pierre lescure
vous bruno vous êtes un petit peu à la
tête de la rébellion un autre un peu le
che guevara locale j'aime bien ça ils
aiment bien tu aimes bien salée
j'étais bien là non c'est à dire que
j'avais couture on vous aime pas voilà
non je dis il dit qu'il avait pas
d'amour et qu'on préférerait qu'ils ne
viennent pas mais dans le contexte de
l'époque dans l'émotion de l'époque
c'est tout à fait justifié et en plus tu
che guevara locale ça fait ya un côté
folklorique c'était on peut quand on
monte une asso c'est qu'on travaille
c'est une lutte syndicats demain je fais
du syndicalisme à ce moment-là tout
bêtement voilà donc tu étais le krasucki
locale voilà je préfère
bien
et bien quand même quelques c'est
l'époque où l'action de vivendi chute
terriblement à la bourse et que
peut-être qu'ils se seraient bien passés
des délais des veines des guignols sur
le groupe non ça je ne sais pas une
mince est libre de le faire je suppose
et à l'époque qu'ils étaient contents
qu'on les fasse ouais alors martin et on
lui remet des mails on lui remet vos
mails qui ont été pris au a priori dans
ma mail boxe quand même
quelqu'un peut rentrer dans votre mail
de boxe facilement
ouais je pense oui je pense mais dans
tout dans toutes les grandes entreprises
comme ça il ya un service informatique
et ses services informatiques et en
réseau et quand on a un problème
informatique on appelle le service on
leur dit j'ai un problème sur mon
ordinateur j'arrive pas à faire si
j'arrive pas à ça ils nous disent je
prends la main ouais à la clé devant
notre écran est un type qui prend la
main c'est à dire qu'il va dans notre
ordinateur il se balade ils ouvrent des
trucs qui n'enferment d'autres et nous
on est là je sais ça bouge tout seul
évidemment il nous dit c'est réparé
vas-y salut bruno bonne journée au
revoir au travail donc l'ordinateur
n'est pour les ordinateurs personnels
ordinateurs d'entreprise ils font ce
qu'ils veulent avec donc il y avait pas
de mails compromettants puisque c'est
l'ordinateur de l'entreprise y'a pas de
mails compromettants sur mon nom alors
sur quel genre domaine comprend sherpa
je sais pas que fait ce que fait ce
pierre martinet d'après ce qu'ils
racontent ils récupèrent une liste de
vos appels téléphoniques sur votre
portable les numéros entrant les numéros
sortants d'ailleurs le flic qui lui a
donné avoué cette semaine les donne pas
à martine et ils les donnent un type qui
s'appelle gilbert borelli il les donne à
d'ailleurs il n'a pas démissionné du
sénat j'ai vu que calais l'un avait
démissionné lui non il toujours à canal
bah oui c'est pour ça que les flics
l'ont donné à lui le ficav ou
alors c'est bizarre parce que pourquoi
est ce que il avait besoin d'avoir la
liste de vos appels entrants et sortants
puisque de toute façon c'est payé par la
société il ya une facture qui arrivait
chez sfr c'est mon téléphone privé c'est
préfère c'est orange à ses abonnés à
canal on a laissé faire comme téléphone
de boulot et orange pour ses téléphones
tranquille donc c'est vrai on a tous
deux téléphones un téléphone privé un
téléphone de donc de flics donnent
sa saveur justice qui dira comment ça
s'est passé exactement ce que ça par
contre ça m'intéresse énormément ouais
j'ai envie de savoir comment ça se passe
quand un flic entre un ex flic entre
dans une société privée qu'il garde des
contacts avec son ancien corps qui
l'administration et que ces contacts
sont transversaux directement sans qu'on
ait besoin de passer par
même si on regarde toi on sera
obligatoire des choses comme ça cc c'est
un fond c'est que ça puisse exister on
se dit bien que ça peut exister j'ai un
copain passe moi les coups de fil d'un
mec mais c'est aussi simple que ça
d'avoir des coups de fil c'est
impossible c'est inconcevable c'était
vrai dire que tous les coups de fil sans
écouter puisqu'on peut demander ceux de
bruno gaccio qu'est ce que j'aimerais
avoir les tiens
tout est très goûté ça rend parano non
du tout un bon je refuse la paranoïa
avant je refuse de deux d'avoir à un
mètre des antivols je refuse de me
méfier de tout je veux pas vivre comme
ça c'est pas une vi on m'a forcé à vivre
ça je l' ai appris après je refuse
aujourd'hui de faire attention attention
de téléphone je veux pas faire ça je
veux vivre tranquillement merde il ya
des lois dans ce pays ou pas ce qu'a
fait monsieur sox en train de t'ecouter
la cannelle
il y avait des caméras d'entonner
mission
alors ensuite on suggère à martinez de
vous coller une fille dans les pattes et
de demander à cette fille de porter
plainte pour viol sympathique non
c'est l'aspect le plus marrant quoi
mais ils n'ont pas fait de mal
ouais je sais pas si c'est dommage parce
que jusqu'au moment où la fille vient
c'est rigolo qui compte elle porte
plainte pour viol c'est pas marrant
marrant
piéger des gens face est passé horrible
il en est drôle d'idée quand même là il
ya une histoire de la drogue dont
scooter aussi pourquoi dans le scooter
ouais
ça va
donc l'église on va lui mettre de la
drogue dans son scooter apprend balles
arrêtées pour possession de drogue voilà
bah oui oui c'est vraiment pas marrant
moi je veux que la justice le dise là on
ya un côté léger quand on en parle comme
ça pour moi c'est extrêmement lourdes
avoir d'être passé quand même à deux
fois rien parce que je lis les journaux
je lis le point par exemple où il ya une
enquête qui est faite autour des stups
way où il ya forcément à l'intérieur des
stups des gens puisqu'il ya une
commission rogatoire si j'ai bien lu le
point qui dit donc à une autorisation à
m'écouter à me suivre c'est quand même
un truc terrible sur la foi de quoi
qu'est ce que ça veut dire mais qu'est
ce que d'où ça sort que je suis tout
d'un coup suspects au point qu'une
commission rogatoire et des flics si
c'est un montage ce qu'on appelle un
chantier si c'est un montage c'est
extrêmement grave je veux savoir quel
flic à la brigade des stups la faiblesse
a encore une fois ça de justice de le
dire
je m'en remets à la justice de mon pays
comme on dit vêtements est-ce que tu
savais que c'était aussi important
finalement d'habitude ça se fait contre
les hommes politiques se fait rarement
contre des sas tradition politique et
affirment des trucs là moi je veux que
la justice le dise si ça s'est fait
comme des hommes politiques des exemples
ya eu des exemples ça me fait un point
commun avec bonnie seront aussi ce récit
de me coller une [ __ ] mois là
[Musique]
alors d'après ce qu'on comprend en
lisant le bouquin de martin et c'est
toute l'idée c'était que vous soyez pas
à l'antenne en septembre cette année là
quoi c'est ce que j'ai lu enfin comment
ils et démerdez vous qu'ils soient pas
inventé dans 70 vous faites comment
voulez vous démerder ouais ils sont cons
parce que c'est l'émission qui marche le
mieux
car henin c'est peut-être pas non mais c
est peut-être pas bien informés
finalement non mais voilà c'est c'est
une histoire de cornecul on pourrait
dire
me me virer de canal c'est extrêmement
simple j'ai un contrat d'auteur - ils
s'arrêtent tous les 30 juin et reprend
tous les 5 août donc on ne renouvelle
pas c'est fini par ailleurs j'ai un cdi
de cadre au sens large à l'époque je dis
que la direction ne me plaît pas ça
s'appelle une faute lourde on me vire et
c'est terminé pas besoin d'aller en plus
ça lire ou faire des photos de mes
enfants des amis dans une maison ça se
voit ça c'est
ça reste un peu là c'est un truc assez
incompréhensible dans le bouquin est
pourquoi ils sont les fers toutes ces
photos de vous dans le midi comme ça
c'est servez à quoi c'est exactement
pour ça que je dépose une plainte contre
x c'est exactement pour ça que je me
constitue partie civile je porte à la
connaissance de la justice des faits que
je trouve délictueuse apporte la preuve
que ces faits sont réels avéré puisque
j'aime le dossier
après la justice doit enquêter sur le
pourquoi moi j'ai quatre questions à
simplement qui
quand comment et pourquoi qu' il y en a
au moins un qui est identifié mais ça ne
s'est levé hier qu'elle martinet oui il
a dit j'ai fait ça je vous ai suivi j'ai
fait les photos j'ai préparé des trucs
j'ai très bien lui s'est identifié il en
dénonce deux autres borelli caïla c'est
quand même grave de dénoncer des gens
jusqu'à preuve du contraire borély et
câlins sont innocents donc moi je veux
que la justice il a porté plainte
d'ailleurs il apporté plein de câlins
donc très bien que la justice l'ait se
démerdent pour me dit à moi qui suis
quand même la victime ce qui s'est passé
entre monsieur martinez et monsieur
borély et monsieur qu'elles vont se
démerder je veux surtout pas être au
milieu mois qu'ils se débrouillent c'est
leur problème si monsieur brayer
monsieur k n 1 10 on n'a pas donné il
faut qu'il faut qu'ils apportent un peu
d'éléments ils peuvent aussi dire c'est
au dessus il faut aussi dire c'est
parallèle il publie je sais pas mais ça
je veux que la justice aille au bout de
ça moi j'irai donc quand on va vous
photographier comme ça dans le sud là ya
pas vraiment de raison on fait rien de
spécial là vous êtes dans votre
restaurant vous allez à la pêche fait du
vélo il ya un an à la pêche non je fais
du vélo j'ai fait des pâtes
jeu sert à table
c'est pas extrêmement contrôlons
compromettant de dire regardez ce
monsieur il a une famille une maison des
amis il leur fait des pâtes je ne suis
pas franchement compromis là dedans
est-ce que c'est par pairage pour vous
casser la tête au coin d'un bois ça je
veux que la justice le dise c'est encore
une fois se disant ouais ben je veux pas
répondre à la télévision ces jeux je
parlerai plus après j'en fais je fais
chez toi et après j'arrête voilà c'est
ils ont été contre son formateur en plus
des casques basse et la moitié school
comme je suis ouais c'est vraiment qu'on
réalise on fait les comptes il aurait
mieux fait de le faire à 40 0
je suis content que ça vienne de toi
mais voilà en restant karl zéro il ya à
part si tu as vraiment envie de
connaître les horaires de train pour
2010 aucune raison d'y écouter
bon alors
le problème c'est qu'à canal n'y a pas
que vous qui avez été victime de ce
genre de traitement il ya mon ami alex
berger pour molex un pareil alexa ray
joel on s'est appelé évidemment c'est du
thème et a vu qu est ce que j'ai dit à
l'état quelque chose donc il doit avoir
le dossier dans les jours qui viennent
voilà et lui aussi il aurait des photos
de sa famille il y aurait d espionnage
sur des comptes en banque il aurait
alors encore une fois dans quel but il
n'y a pas de scooter avec ce je
comprends pas
non il ya alex et thibodeau enfin il ya
plein de gens comme ça qu'on connaît
moins mais disons que voilà thibodeau
est un des présidents il était président
de multi thématiques des choses
ben je sais pas sympa comme boîte non
c'est je vais faire corporate là il ya
un moment l'amalgamme qui ai fait la
sphère canal+ la sphère qui s'est passé
donc un hâle publie je veux bien parce
que ça s'est passé dans canal+ je sais
un peu court de dire c'est canal+ dans
son ensemble s'il ya des gens qui ont eu
le pouvoir un moment et les moyens
d'exercer ce pouvoir de façon stupide
estime
et qu'ils ont créé un état dans l'état
dans le canal il faut le dire si ça au
dessus il faut le dire aussi mais pour
l'instant il ya martinez a c'est sûr il
y en a deux qui sont identifiés qui se
défendent comme ils peuvent
ça le juge va le dire mais là dessus
c'est vraiment à la justice à lenquête
de le faire toute autre forme je sais
bien que dans les journaux si ça va se
mettre en vrille à un moment on va dire
qu à mal si canal l'algérien pas canard
la meinau à france télévisions n'a
jamais eu de trucs comme ça quoi
je te savais tout peut-être que oui
naïve non je sais pas naïve je croyais
peut-être que tu si elle peut suivre
si tu devais suivre c'est pas bien voilà
par était alors tu ne fais pas de gaulle
et
alors non mais sérieusement quand même
ce qui est grave là dedans c'est
finalement la privatisation de la police
squad comores en irak c'est la
privatisation de l'armée ici si la
privatisation de la policière qui a but
d anthologie les mecs font pour ceux qui
les paye quoi c'est fini bah c'est
exactement sage si j'ai bien noté
monsieur de villepin il a dit
s'intéresser à ce problème là en disant
qu'ils avaient quand même quelque chose
d'extrêmement grave et là il ya un nom
pour ça quand il ya un état par allen
qui fait pression sur des gens que cet
état ne répond à aucun citoyen c'est le
fascisme c'est rien d'autre que ça ils
n'ont comptes à rendre à personne dans
une boîte privée ils sont pas élus les
mecs n'avaient pas de comptes à rendre
s'il n'ya pas alors là je vais prendre
un peu sa défense parce que je sais
qu'il va se faire allumer mais le pire
martin est là ouais
bon moi je ne sera jamais mon pote il y
avoue à demi pardonnée ouais mais moi il
m'a suivi il a fait il a fait il l'a
fait ça sera pas mon pote on prend un
peu notre petit déjeuner ensemble il n'a
pas fait dans le changement il n'a pas
fait la fille dans les pattes il n'a pas
fait l'an ils à vivre dans le scooter
est gelée vu martin eh ouais je lui ai
parlé un sympa
c'est un non mais c'est un type qui est
qui à un moment écrit ce livre en
sachant qu'ils risquent d'aller en taule
ou en sachant qu'il pourra plus jamais
travailler dans ce genre de métier là
donc il prend un risque quand même qui
est énorme donc il ya quelque chose
derrière il a des billes ce garçon et il
a un côté un peu chevalier blanc il a
envie d'être un héros je ne sais quoi en
tout cas si elle dans le livre quand ils
me donnent le livre on sourit quand il
ya le dossier et le livre et qu'on lit
l'ensemble du livre parce que quand on
lit ma partie on se dit c'est c'est
grand guignol quand on lit sa formation
quand on lit ce qu'a fait ce type dans
les services secrets quand on lit le
parachutisme la guerre à beyrouth ou des
trucs et qu'on voit qu'il applique les
mêmes méthodes un mec comme moi qui suis
quand même bon et c'est important je
veux bien l'avouer vérone le clampin de
base de la télé il ne faut pas oublier
qu'on fait que de la télé thierry ont
fait que ça
peut influer sur les trucs très
important tu sais bien ça doit se voir
les ligneurs quel pouvoir j'ai fait dix
ans qu'il est là je suis noir sinon on
ne serait pas là
les guignols c'est la preuve qu'on est
dans une démocratie qui fonctionne à peu
près notre chaîne nous laisse faire
parce qu'il
est peut-être parce que ça marche les
précédents et messins eux ils le font
parce que ça marche mais il nous laisse
faire on est libre de faire ce qu'on
veut de temps en temps quand on
égratigne corporate ils viennent gueuler
mais on ne fait pas ça mais oui mais ils
ont droit de gueuler c'est leur rôle
c'est les patrons donc ça prouve qu'on
est dans une démocratie le fait que des
flics
officiels donnent à des flics officieux
de quoi enquêté pour faire pression sur
des gens dans des sociétés privées est
là on n'est plus dans une démocratie on
est dans quoi ces pitres la république
là et j'ai l'impression que on devrait
se pencher sur ce problème mon cas très
bien je suis ravi que ça ait déclenché
ça si c'est juste pour s'arrêter à dire
un bain gaccio il a été suivi à ils ont
émis des plus tôt mais on va pas arriver
on va arriver à rien par contre si
sérieusement un juge en quête le
pourquoi il ya une commission rogatoire
sur moi pourquoi j'aimerais bien savoir
quel est le juge qui l'a délivré 7
l'émission en tirant sur la foi de
calmer en fait on instrumentalise on a
des services publics pour des intérêts
privés c'est ça qui est grasse moi parce
que je le dis et je suis à faire des
prises de sang s'il faut je ne suis pas
drogué dernière fois que j'ai pris de la
course en 1981 non mais t'as n'a pas
trouvé depuis
doit passer
dix mois bon tu as porté plainte la cei
et bien sûr c'est vrai ça y est ça a été
fait mardi dans l'après-midi way et
qu'est ce qu'ils disent à canal tu l'as
vu monsieur mais euh oui je les
rencontre et ouais alors ben il est
comme moi il tombe de sa chaise il
m'assure que dans qu'il n'était pas au
courant de ces agissements si ces
agissements ont eu lieu pour l'instant
lui il fait un peu comme moi d'ailleurs
ans et on a des points communs avec make
up il s'en tient à une chose martinet a
dit des choses ouais martinez c'est sur
l'épreuve moi je les ai dans un dossier
mais le napa le dossier évidemment je
lui assuré que c'était vraiment martinet
accuse borély et qu'elle lui il a fait
son boulot il a
parlé probablement un câlin qui a donné
sa démission après aurélie n'a toujours
pas donné donc ça veut dire que il a
plus confiance en bourrique ans c'est
quand même les flics ont donné à bord
est liée non pas à kayhan enfin bon ils
se débrouillent pour l'instant il en est
là et il a bien raison d'en être là et
de laisser faire la justice il m'a
prouvé d'avoir porté plainte il m'a
remercié de ne pas avoir un mis-en-cause
canal ce qui est vrai qu'à mal n'est pas
en cause dans cette histoire c'est au
mieux deux types dans canal ou un
service dans canal donc tout est
relativement clair entre nous maintenant
la justice est saisie elle va bosser
j'espère si la plainte est recevable je
pense qu'elle l'est ces mecs si la
planète était pas recevable je tomberai
de machin aussi il va y avoir une
instruction moi je respecterai le secret
de l'instruction s'agirait pas la télé
demain ils ont fait ce choix là ça je
ferai pas des gentils c'est déjà pas mon
genre dans un truc comme ça je le ferai
encore moins voilà mais j'espère
vraiment qu'elle irait au bout par
contre tous les sentiments que j'ai tout
ce que j'ai appris toutes les rumeurs
tous les mails j'en ferai part au juge
en disant voilà il ya ça qui était vrai
il ya ça qui était faux et je lui dirai
tout mais aujourd'hui je dirais pas à la
télévision dit dans un journal voilà et
ça va être quand tu reviens pour me dire
le résultat
j'espère revenir avant pour un livre
avant saison l'arrière l'unami à sauver
je ne sais quoi mais alors avec tout ça
on parle plus de adolphe 2
c'est vrai que si je voulais arrondir
les angles adolphe dodo ça va loin ouais
mais c'est pas nous qui avons commencé
et quand il ya 115 évêques dans aux
cardinaux dans un conclave et qu'on
choisit celui qui a dit les hitler on va
un poil loin il y en a cent quatorze
autres pourquoi celui-là c'est ce qu'a
dit schneidermann et dieu sait si je
suis pas d'accord avec les verts m'a
souvent oui mais il a dit il a dit dans
tous les évêques qui étaient là ils ont
pris celui qui était dans les jeunesses
hitlériennes la même s'il n'a rien fait
dans sa carrière ça s'appelle du laisser
aller à un moment on se dit c'est pas
grave il ya quand même quel beau symbole
pour montrer qu'on peut être allemand
malgré tout moment était donc gêné seat
la rédemption ça fait partie du système
mais je trouve quand même qui aurait
laissé aller il ya des tâches qui sont
indélébiles on devrait lui dire il avait
fait carrière dans le catholicisme de
façon quand même assez correct abuja un
bon job la cause par les cinq longues
c'est simplement un moment il a désigné
comme symbole un moment le symbole on
lui dit tu as dit heil hitler une fois
dans ta vie donc non excusez-nous non
voilà même jour là les médecins même si
la reddition et même si j'essaie
d'accord voilà ben voila tu vois
pourquoi on a fait ça merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un peu
de bleu